so FBI director James Comey has now
revealed that the 650,000 treasure trove
of emails the FBI discovered on Anthony
Weiner's laptop doesn't contain any
information that would make him rethink
his decision not to recommend indictment
for Hillary Clinton according to the
Washington Post quote the agents work at
first seemed endless they had to use
special software to sift through 650,000
emails but they accomplished this
formidable task and then Comey announced
that quote all of the communications
that were to or from Hillary Clinton
while she was Secretary of State had not
changed our conclusions most of the
emails but not all reportedly duplicated
other emails turned over by Clinton
earlier or discovered by the FBI that
statement notably did not say that the
Clinton Foundation haven't let off the
hook
it hasn't been new wiki leaks over the
email demonstrate further corruption
from Hillary sending classified emails
to her maid to prince to chelsea
allegedly using foundation dollars to
sponsor her wedding so Hillary's still
corrupt and yes she's still a criminal
and according to the Democrats Hillary's
back to being innocent and calm he's
back to being a saint like wonder dude
but the real question is this what in
the world was James Comey thinking well
in July Comey refused to recommend
Clinton for indictment he did so by
changing the law itself requiring a
level of intent and that simply did not
exist in the regulations those
regulations demand merely proving a
gross negligence it's hard to get more
grossly negligent with classified
material than setting up a private
server in a bathroom and then funneling
classified information through it and
making it vulnerable to hack in the
process or by the way sending that
material to your hire janitorial help
for printing it's no surprise commis let
her off the hook again once you change
the standard of the law you'd actually
need to find an email from Hillary to
Vladimir Putin sending him the names of
American spies in order to incite her
but here's what actually happened here
Comey brushed a letter off then you rush
to get himself off then he rushed to let
her off again when the polls went south
no wonder nobody trusts the FBI now it's
a political tool no matter what happens
tomorrow
Hillary will never be trusted by the
American people and nobody will trust
James Comey or Loretta Lynch to do
justice that means the American people
won't give Hillary any sort of bully
pulpit or any credibility when she makes
her case to the American people maybe
perhaps that's the only good news to
come from his Horror Show of an election
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
so much to get to today here on the Ben
Shapiro show it is the day before
Election Day so I will give you my
election prediction 2016 I'll give you
the state-by-state breakdown I'll tell
you how I think the popular vote is
gonna come down but first we have to say
hello to one of our sponsors Bowland
branch so I do not sleep well at night
because I'm too busy killing terrorists
but when I'm not busy killing terrorists
I have to sleep and the only way that I
can sleep well at night is by is by
sleeping in the set of sheets that are
actually comfortable after a bowline
branch it makes these fantastic sheets
there are hundred percent cotton organic
cotton they're really really soft they
breathe
they're really nice luxury sheets can
cost up to like a thousand dollars these
cost a couple hundred bucks and they are
totally totally worth it in fact one of
the problems with ball and branch sheets
is that once you have a set of ball and
branch eats you want to throw out all
your other sheets like the well our
cleaning lady put it put a new set of
sheets on the bed the other day and I
immediately strip the sheets off the bed
we went back to the Bowlin branch
because the sheets are so great I'm
actually gonna have to buy a couple more
sets of Bolin branch sheets just because
they are so comfortable they really are
that comfortable they're great
apparently three u.s. presidents sleep
on ball and branch sheets which means
that Hillary Clinton has never slept on
Poland branch eats coz bill sleeps on
ball and branch sheets in any case if
you want these kind of if you want the
sheets ball and branch calm promo code
Ben is the place to get them Boland
branch calm promo code Ben is 50 bucks
off your first set of sheets it's like
150 bucks instead of 200 it smelled Bo
LL and branch calm and use the promo
code Ben get that $50 off and let them
know that we set you and and it is that
I'm telling you like I'm not fibbing
about the quality of these sheets there
really are top-notch put those on the
helix mattress and they are just
spectacular okay so what's going on in
the world nate silver who's sort of the
elections guru he says the donald trump
is relatively close to a path to winning
here's what he had to say about Donald
Trump's chances on Sunday so we show
about a three point lead nationally for
Clinton and she's about a two-to-one
favorite the electoral college math is
actually less solid for Clinton than it
was for Obama four years ago were four
years ago we had about a a head in
states totaling three hundred and twenty
some electoral votes
Clinton has about 270 s so she's one
state away
from potentially losing the electoral
college you'd rather be in her shoes
than down on promise but it's not a
terribly safe position give her about a
sixty five point seven about yes okay so
he says sixty five point seven percent
chance of winning and and he says that
that Trump does have a path that
basically he's one state away from
winning this is reflective of the polls
over the weekend so basically in order
for Trump to win he has to win North
Carolina's testament Florida he has to
win Ohio he has to win Nevada and then
he has to a New Hampshire and if he wins
one of the votes in Maine then he takes
the election that is his most plausible
path to victory in this election cycle
which means this sucker could be over
early it is possible that this is is
over you know very early in the evening
if he loses New Hampshire in North
Carolina you can kiss this election
goodnight it's dunzo it's over
turn out the lights four years of
Hillary Clinton's Horror Show okay so
that's where nate silver puts this
election the the democrats either don't
seem particularly certain of this
election or they're just trying to gin
their base to get out by saying it's
closer than it is john podesta says that
he thinks that hillary can hold michigan
she certainly should hold michigan she's
up like five or six points in michigan
and now we're going to Michigan to New
Hampshire to Pennsylvania where they do
it the old-fashioned way everybody votes
on Election Day we feel like we got a
lead in Michigan we want to hold on to
it and we think we can do that okay so
he says that they're gonna hold on to
Michigan and and I think that in all
likelihood they will Mike Pence is
saying Republicans are coming home this
is shown by the statistics Republicans
are coming back to trump in the late
days of the election because for most
people politics ends up being a team
sport you're just gonna vote for the
person with with the name of the party
by their by their name pence makes the
case for Trump in the closing hours here
we're a hundred percent focused on
bringing home a great victory for the
American people and Republicans are
coming together Chris I was yesterday
with Speaker Paul Ryan in Wisconsin a
couple days before I was with Governor
Doug Ducey
in Arizona last night here in Virginia
with Ed Gillespie Republicans are coming
home and recognizing that we need to
elect Donald Trump as a next president
reelect a strong Republican majority and
Republicans are coming home with
independents and Democrats at their side
to make sure that that hill
Clinton is never elected president of
the United States okay so there are a
couple of things that are that people
aren't questioning about the polls one
is they don't know what the turnouts
actually going to be like is there the
secret base of front voters who are
gonna show up out of the woodwork and
just vote for Trump I think that's
unlikely I do I mean I've yet to meet a
closeted Trump supporter they don't
really exist as far as I can tell
Trump supporters tend to be very loud
and very proud about who they're voting
for
I'm not saying a lot of people even in
California who are and this is anecdotal
to be sure but now we're talking in the
realm of anecdotal because there are no
real statistical studies but I really
doubt I do doubt there a lot of Trump
supporters who are we're not going to
are simply lying to pollsters or they're
not registering in the polls the other
possibility is a lot of the independents
are gonna swing the Trump and the polls
are not really supporting that idea
either so now I'm gonna give you my
breakdown of how I think this election
is actually gonna go so here's my
prediction and you can take it to the
bank or not as the case may be here
here's where I think this comes down to
so in order for Trump to win as I say he
has to Anora line of Florida Ohio Iowa
and Nevada and then yes win one more
state New Hampshire Colorado Virginia
Wisconsin Michigan or Pennsylvania all
the talk about Minnesota it is gonna
happen he's gonna get blown out in
Minnesota so let's go through those
really quickly North Carolina so far
three million ballots have been cast in
North Carolina which is a little bit
more than we're casting early voting in
2012 is like 2.8 million in 2012 the
Hispanic turnout is up a little bit
which is good news for Hillary the black
turnout is apparently down rather
dramatically which is really bad news
for Hillary Clinton because she needs
the black turnout in order to drive her
over the top
Nate Cohn of the New York Times
estimated as of October 31st he said
about 2.9 million people had voted in
North Carolina out of the 4.6 million
who would eventually vote that's a huge
number of people who vote early in North
Carolina
he says based on the voting history and
demographic characteristics of those
people we think Hillary leads in North
Carolina by about six percentage points
that seems real high to me 538 gives
Hillary a 50 point six percent shot to
beat Trump in North Carolina now I will
say Trump doesn't have a ground game so
it's possible the polls are off in the
in the other direction as well that the
Democrats are really gonna get out the
vote they're gonna send people to bust
people to the polls they're gonna make
sure all their elderly voters get out to
vote and the turnout game is what
decides North Carolina I think that
Hillary will end up winning nor
Carolina but I do think that'll be very
close and I think that Richard Burr
who's the senator from North Carolina
manned up maintaining his seat he's the
Republican in Florida it's also
basically a dead heat according to 538
it's essentially a dead heat in Florida
between Clinton and Trump there's been
some conflicting information about the
early voting originally there was a case
being made that the early voting was
really good for Trump in the last four
days the early voting has shifted a
little bit more toward Hillary Clinton
apparently very very heavy Hispanic
turnout in the early voting in Florida
apparently some 6.1 million ballots have
already been cast in the state of
Florida Democrats lead Republicans by
just half a percentage points there's a
poll out today that shows the people who
plan on voting Election Day are going to
vote heavily Trump the question is how
many of those people there are and how
heavily Trump that is so this one is
definitely up in the air
but if Hispanics vote disproportionately
in in Florida and they're not all Cuban
Hispanics then it's possible that Trump
loses Florida as well I think that he's
gonna lose both North Carolina and
Florida
it's a pessimistic vision for Trump but
again he hasn't spent any time building
a ground game so I think that's likely
Ohio I think Trump will win CNN says
that Hillary trails Obama's numbers
substantially in the early voting 538
gives him a 65% chance of winning the
state that's solid enough for me I will
say that Trump wins Ohio I think he's
gonna win Iowa as well he's a big in
Iowa the latest poll from the Des Moines
Register gives him a seven-point lead
there in Nevada Clinton is gonna win so
before Trump was up pretty big or at
least yet he'd drawn into the lead in
the last few weeks last 3-4 weeks
Hillary has a major advantage in the
early voting
according to John Ralston who does
elections analysis for one of the local
news stations in Vegas he says about 770
thousand votes have been cast which is
about two-thirds of the entire vote in
the state of Nevada and II suppose an
election day turnout of 450,000 voters
Trump needs to win on Tuesday by 10
points to win this is almost impossible
so assume that he loses Nevada and now
remember these are all states he needs
to win if he loses one of these states
he's done he has to win all of these
states he cannot afford to lose any of
these states unless he's gonna win one
of the outliers like Michigan or
Pennsylvania we'll get to those in just
a second in New Hampshire New Hampshire
is apparently really close right now in
the latest polling average but you sorta
have to look over the last year for the
last year
New Hampshire by as much as double
digits there's about a one-week spate
right after the Comey announcement of
the renewed FBI investigation or
suddenly Trump was ahead by anywhere
from one to three points now there are a
couple new polls that show Hillary back
up I think the Clinton is probably gonna
win New Hampshire Colorado Clinton is
gonna match Obama's numbers in the early
voting that means that she's probably
gonna win Colorado Virginia which used
to be a Republican state has not voted
Republican now probably for the last 12
years the last time they voted
Republican was 2004 a lot of the people
who live in Washington DC have moved
into suburban Virginia and they've been
infusing Northern Virginia with his blue
feel so Virginia's likely to go for
Hillary Clinton
Wisconsin polling looks bad for Trump
Michigan polling looks bad for Trump
he's spending an awful lot of time there
you saw Podesta a minute ago saying that
he thinks that that Hillary's gonna pull
it out I think that she's gonna win by a
relatively large margin there
Pennsylvania Clinton is expected to win
there 538 gives Trump a 23% likelihood
of a pickup so I know I'm not gonna give
you the rah-rah speech today I'm not
gonna lie to you about what's happening
here I'm not gonna lie to you the Trump
is on the verge of victory I don't think
he is I think there's some other people
you know who have been suggesting
otherwise I know there's a piece by
Henry Olsen over at national review
where he says the polls aren't taking
into account the factors I mentioned
before you know the turnout game from
Trump the idea of the missing Trump
voter who is secretly hiding and just
hiding from pollsters in a basement
somewhere I don't think that's real my
final tally is I think the Trump ends up
with 217 electoral votes I think Hillary
is over 322 electoral votes which means
he went slightly more electoral votes
than Romney Ted and and more obviously
than McCain said but still gets blown
out in pretty handy fashion that's in
the electoral college I think in the
popular vote he will lose by more than
Romney did I think he's gonna win Iowa I
think he'll probably win Ohio
maybe not but I think that he's more he
will certainly win Iowa I don't know if
you didn't win Ohio but in any case in
the popular vote I think that people are
under estimating the level of hatred
that Democrats and leftists have for
Trump and it's not just because they
think he's conservative okay they would
have hated Cruz also or Rubio it's
because of who Trump is they don't like
the stuff that Trump says I think some
of that is justified they think Trump is
an unpalatable nutjob
I think that about a quarter of that is
I think unpalatable is right nutjob
think is a little bit less charitable
but in any case I think that you're
going to see heavy turnout in places
like New York and California just as a
way for for leftists to to virtue signal
to their friends that they voted against
Trump so I think that the popular vote
margin will be larger than Romney
even though right now popular vote
margin the polls show anywhere from two
point nine to three point three points
in the spread I think that the final
result is going to be something like
Hillary Clinton 49 or 50 to Donald Trump
44 I think it'll be a five or six point
victory which is a pretty sweeping
victory for Hillary Clinton now all of
this should make you pretty sad given
the fact that we didn't have to nominate
this guy you know there's a poll out
today that shows what would have
happened if we'd nominated for example
MIT Romney who I didn't support for the
nomination if you had nominated Mitt
Romney he would have clobbered for he
would have clobbered Clinton 50 to 40 if
Obama had run against Trump by the way
this is why you can't trust the people
who say well look Trump's a better
candidate than Romney he's gonna win
more electoral votes he's not running
against Barack Obama he's running
against Hillary Clinton legitimately the
worst major Party nominee in the history
of American politics except for The
we ran so it's just it's
devastating if Obama had run against
Trump he would've beaten him according
to these polls 53 to 41 53 241 which is
just devastating so that's how the polls
stack up that's how all of this stacks
up now I want to go through and we will
go through in just a moment sort of the
final arguments on both sides because if
there's been one thing that's true of
this election is that every negative
thing that each side says about the
other is true everything they say about
themselves is a lie and we'll go through
that and we'll talk about what impact
that has on our politics in just a
moment but first we have to say hello to
our friends over at Birch gold so if you
haven't been if you haven't been looking
at the economy lately
it looks like it's it's relatively
volatile a recession is sort of expected
any minute there's a good case to be
made that there's a recession in the
United States every eight to ten years
which means that we're due if there is
to be a recession that will probably hit
the stock market in the real estate
market what it won't hit is gold every
time there's a recession the price of
gold tends to go up so if you're
interested in investing in precious
metals as a hedge against inflation if
you're interested in investing in
precious metals as a hedge against drops
in the real estate and stock market then
you're going to want to go to
birchgold.com slash Bennett's
birchgold.com
/ Ben they also have a program helps you
shift your money over from an IRA and
401k into precious metals without tax
consequences as always make sure you ask
all your questions get all the
information you want about the
investments they also give you a 16-page
free kit about gold and silver and how
it can help your investment portfolio
when you're ready to invest in precious
metals talk to my friends at
birchgold.com / been a plus rating with
the Better Business Bureau okay so the
media just just to point this out what
this election has done you know people
wanted this to be the burn it all down
election and in a sense they got exactly
what they were looking for everything
was burned down some for the good some
for the ill for the ill I would say the
conservatism has been burned out
hollowed out from the inside by a lot of
the Trump movement although I think that
after this election you will see an
attempt to to restore conservatism not
of the bush variety but of a new
conservative libertarian variety that
will have to be a new conservatism but
based on constitutional conservative
principles and not establishment Arian
compromised principles I think that will
happen
but in the meantime conservatism has
been harmed pretty severely by the Trump
candidacy that's a bad thing but on the
good side the media have just fallen
apart so it has now been revealed and
this really is amazing that apparently
apparently this is according to media ID
NC research director Lauren Dylan since
a pair of emails to CNN staffers with
the hope that they would use to her
emails these questions that she wrote
for them to ask Donald Trump the first
email had the subject line Trump
questions for CNN and it says Wolf
Blitzer is interviewing Trump on Tuesday
ahead of his foreign policy address on
Wednesday please send me thoughts by
10:30 a.m. tomorrow this is this is from
Lauren Dillon the DNC research director
she wrote that to her folks the idea
being that she was then I'm gonna funnel
those questions over to CNN and they
would ask the questions there's another
letter that suggested the same thing
about Ted Cruz that letter said it was
from Dylan to her friend said CNN is
looking for questions please send some
topical interesting ones maybe a couple
on Fiorina someone please take point and
send them all together by 3:00 p.m. so
in other words the DNC was directly
coordinating with people over at CNN to
ask questions to Donald Trump and Ted
Cruz
that is amazing thing the media have
destroyed all their credibility that may
be the only good thing about this
election cycle the Democrats credibility
has also
destroyed by the way and we'll get to
that in just a second as we as we see
the Democrats final pitch but to see
that you have to go to daily wire comm
and become a subscriber I mean just do
it it's eight bucks a month right now if
you get the annual subscription you get
a free copy of my of my book true
allegiance which is doing really well
you got a free signed copy I'll
autograph at 40 you can treasure it
forever hand it down to your children
sell it on eBay once it's yours it's
yours there's nothing I can do about it
but eight bucks a month just forego that
hamburger to get a little less fat and
and then you can be a member at Daley
wire.com be part of our mailbag we're
adding new benefits all the time we have
a lot of exciting things planned for
subscribers this year that you're gonna
want to be a part of daily wired comms
become a subscriber and and make sure
you join us at the the most populous and
the largest conservative podcast in the
United States